that's drake wearing a jacket that has
plenty of
logos on there for everyone who believes
in the drake curse good luck tomorrow
because they're all on there so i don't
know what the drake curse is apparently
if drake likes a team the team stinks
well i mean that is that i guess yes
i've heard that before but i i think
it's not i mean i feel like ever since
he's been a fan of the toronto rappers
raptors they've been pretty damn good so
i give him a lot of credit for going
with some teams that are not necessarily
front runners all the time and and he
goes with some teams that got to earn
their way he's a loyal toronto fan i
know that i like that
he needs to do the snoop dogg thing just
wait for the team to become great and
then jump on the bandwagon that's what
snoop dogg always does he's a steelers
fan except in those years when the
patriots are better all right
the worst teams get their reward tonight
because they're at the top of the draft
stack chris give me the story line that
you're watching the most going into
tonight i i think the number one thing
is you know it of course has a lot to do
with the number one pick is where josh
rosen ends up when all said and done
yeah i do believe that the arizona
cardinals are picking kyler murray and
how does it all unshake as the first
round unfolds and where does josh rosen
end up i would expect that we get that
answer uh before the night is over uh
maybe not maybe a weight lasts into
tomorrow night into the second round
until that finally gets decided but uh
regardless that would be my favorite
storyline
yeah and also i'm i'm going to be
looking at your former head coach john
gruden he's got three first-round draft
picks he's got to make them count he's
already told mike mayhawk don't mess it
up even though gruden is the guy who's
got final say they have to make people
forget about khalil mack and amari
cooper two guys who were traded away to
get those first round picks you know i
say it all the time the whole purpose of
the draft is to get yourself a lottery
ticket that scratches off as a winner
when you get the winner you don't trade
it in for another lottery ticket which
is precisely what they did especially
with mac so the pressure is on tonight
to make it count to find another kalino
mac but don't take them at number four
don't take a password number four
because you're gonna be compared
relentlessly to mack who was taking
number five five years ago so how the
raiders play this board do they stay put
with their three picks do they move up
do they move down do they try to
accumulate more picks do they try to
swoop back into the bottom of round one
and have four first rounders we'll see
but that for me is going to be something
that is very fascinating and you know
for most teams you if you're a fan of
that team they make their pick and then
you just kind of sit back and watch for
the raiders i mean you're you're locked
in all night you know if you're a
raiders fan you're going to be exhausted
when this is over chris
i said it yesterday i'll say it again
this is the most important draft in the
history of the oakland raiders franchise
i mean this is huge you got a coach
that's 10 years 100 million contract
you're about to move to las vegas
it's all needs to be set up uh for
something special or at least for a team
that is highly competitive when they do
move to las vegas so that transition
moves uh you know moves nicely or
smoothly so
i'm with you that is certainly one of
the best story lines another one i'm
interested in you know another team
that's got two picks in the first round
of course is the green bay packers and
we've talked a lot about giants and
oakland raiders but they kind of get
left off of that conversation maybe
because they don't have a desperate need
they don't need the quarterback i do
think we all think they're going to be a
competitive team regardless and in the
playoffs or playoff conversation because
of their quarterback but
i want to see what they're going to do i
mean you know are they going to get
aaron rodgers another weapon you know
that's one thing you know i check the
rule books he's allowed to have a good
running back before he retires they're
allowed to have a run game in green bay
so that would be interesting but they'd
floor with the josh jacobs at the end of
the first round do they get a you know a
receiver at the end of the first round
maybe aj brown or from mississippi
something like that but i am truly
intrigued to see what the green bay
packers do when all said and done
don't you think at a minimum they need
an offensive lineman is it isn't it
incumbent on them after we saw what
happened to aaron rodgers week one of
last year protect this guy a little bit
better he's not going to get faster as
he gets older he's your most important
asset you've got to add blockers in
whatever round you find them in but
you've got to improve your offensive
line especially in that division with
khalil mack with the vikings defense
with trey flowers now in detroit and the
lions trying to get better you've got to
protect aaron rodgers in these very
expensive twilight years of his career
yes you definitely do and i know there's
been a lot of talk that maybe that's
what the packers do at pick number 12
and all that but i just look at the
packers and go i don't think they're
desperate to ha need a first round
offense alignment i'll say that second
round i think there's going to be some
guys there that certainly have some
value but yeah i get what you're saying
i mean with bulaga at right tackle
getting up there in years and he's been
hurt a few times they got to start
thinking about replacements but they got
a guy in jason spriggs so they drafted
out of indiana two years ago in the
second round i believe who i really
think is the heir apparent there you
know they they signed a billy turner in
free agency because really their biggest
issue on the offensive lash line last
year was right guard i mean they had
some of the worst right guard play in
all of football so uh i could see that
being a possibility but i as a fan or
somebody evaluates think there's some
greater needs there get another
difference maker on the front seven with
pick number 12 and get an offensive whip
weapon at pick number 30 is what i'm
kind of rooting for the green bay
packers to do
and by the way the sims draft watch
party tonight if you're in or around new
york city treadwell park 62nd street and
first avenue i i i have you couldn't
call you guys because you can't invite
me oh yeah thanks you're inviting me i'm
in west virginia and it's tonight thank
you so much for that invitation jump on
a plane take your two-hour trip and
drive to pittsburgh airport
on draft day yeah you want me to travel
i do
you can you could paste and copy and
snarky comment from treadwell park don't
worry and we'll throw some tequila's
back
why didn't you invite me at seven
o'clock tonight
it's the same thing i can't do it not
that i would have come anyway
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports